I need to be challenged I need to wake
up each day and break a barrier where
people tell me I can't do it call me a
freak all you want because of my diverse
skill set yeah I'm a double freak but I
enjoy it
hi I'm Dan Spitz I am the master watch
maker I also co-founded the band anthrax
[Music]
the anthrax it was one of the most
successful heavy metal bands in the
history of music we changed the map so
much that people had to come up with a
term for it called fresh metal but in
1995 I've kind of had enough of touring
I had children and a family and I wanted
nothing more to do but have silence in
my life
as far as watchmaking goes I'm a third
generation watchmaker I started taking
apart watches in my grandfather's
jewelry store when I was 8 years old
after 95 I wanted to get my pedigree and
be able to take apart what's considered
complications or just crazy avant-garde
watchmaking
which is the equivalent of thrash metal
in watchmaking the only way to do that
is in Switzerland I was lucky enough to
gain access to a school or six people
are chosen from around the world every
three years
as far as the timepieces that I work on
the watches you usually start a 50,000
and go up to two or three million it is
not with a battery not with a circuit
board you get into two three four
thousand pieces inside a tie piece that
all have to do certain things so if
there's a problem you might have to rip
apart the entire engine we call it a
movement figure out what the problem is
rebuild the watch there's no road map to
the pieces when you're in that zone in
that watch and trying to find that
problem when you finally execute
whatever that is it's a feeling of
euphoria and it's just like when you're
in the recording studio and just like
you when you're on stage and we have
zero room for error and I take that into
my watch making
[Music]
Rita Ito massive angus music - me togusa
comedy septimus Akita dandiya
kita to her major
I found a normal girl yeah multifaceted
[Music]
the Guru in western Java Indonesia is a
quiet place
[Music]
well most of the time I'm not gonna sit
in your booklet up give it that movie
but then activate some more don't love I
meet get on I'm guess I'm unbeatable of
Wasilla white rebellion teenagers rules
and tradition it's an age-old
rock-and-roll story but this time with
the jobs meet the VOB Indonesia's metal
hijabis there's fear de the vocalist and
guitarist who loves hip-hop we D the
drummer a Red Hot Chili Peppers
aficionado then he got CT on the base
who likes her thrash metal bands like
Lamb of God and System of a Down the
fear of being eaten delivery
orin orin been embedded in Isaac's
pharmacy Giannina hip metal punky Peter
Parvin and her hip hop me apparently
Columbia super-gay Jeremiah then tell me
like it like if I care he didn't take
some holiday music often met about
Restrepo
a double operated I am very happy of
Isberg a young woman who secret mission
in culinary job into Quran Karim
sorry juice
since its start in 2014 the band has
seen some success but not without its
critics did you go put my hand up a
little bit up a hobby better I say for
mendelian permit to Samarra and makalah
the piccolo dairy cos theta why I
decided to fly and ranch and what the
dependency vengan possibility music the
Moose is a professional and acknowledge
each other in the machine our Paris
Vendome is at econo consist and a la
música first we are inventing we
subtract the jelly is chaos
[Music]
the most powerful thing about being a
metal singer is the complete release I
teach people how to scream effectively
without damage but I'm also a singing
teacher
my background is Shakespeare and opera
I got known for being a scream teacher
because I figured this out and I'm glad
I did because everyone was trashing
themselves instead of going red I want
most metal kids before they get trained
they think that the only way that you
can get that sound is to feel that way
and that's dangerous because if you feel
that way when you make that sound it
hurts
and release everything I teach them the
least amount of effort to do it and then
they don't trash their vocal cords metal
is like it has a certain behavior and
it's about loyalty it's real
[Music]
whenever people tell us mariachi music
is sacred and you can't change it or
touch it you know and believe me there's
a lot of people that are trying to
convince us like what we're doing is
like a musical sin but in order to
create something noble you have to take
risk you have to do something know how
does something new come about if you
don't change it
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
metallurgy is the first and only
heavy-metal mariachi band in the world
we know we're doing when it comes to
mariachi if we're metallurgy everybody
spent years doing mariachi or Charles we
did mariachi for our life that's how we
made money we use traditional mariachi
instruments it's the same thing that you
would find in a annamaria band doing
what we do is not really not easy to
make a heavy metal song into a metal
achi song you have to invent rhythm and
we basically create patterns and a lot
of people don't see it they're already
here like oh wow that's a new pattern
but the thing is is that we see people
moving to it then we know he did a good
job
[Music]
cover a lot of different types of
advance and everything like something
you guys know like Guns N'Roses
[Music]
Ozzy Osbourne
our core stuff like Slayer not so hard
her stuff like journey huh you name it
with you all
there's times where a song translates
very well and we can pick it up again a
couple hours we can put something
together and sounds really nice
[Music]
we've even traveled to Mexico to go play
over there and not really knowing how
they would accept it because there's a
lot of people that are very traditional
you know they love it because my tea
actually music isn't my life
it's about beauty so sentimental music
enter actually singing about the same
stuff they just do it in their own
different way
[Music]
by integrating the two things we're
showing my TIG people this music is also
beautiful but there's no heavy metal
music is that your music could be
interpreted a different way you know I
think we like that message that's being
sent out
[Music]
the first time like I laid down the
guitar track and then play the fiddle on
top of this it make me you have
goose-bumpy shamanic
[Music]
my name is nature gong-gong burger I am
a musician
marie-jeanne from China but I have a
Mongolian ancestry
so this our Mongolian fiddle we call
that money [ __ ] or in the English we
can say a horse hat fiddle
[Music]
throat singing is a very ancient and
traditional way of singing you press
your throat and you you generate one a
sound but then you generate an over tune
on the top of the within your mouth oh
it sounds like it sounds like to sound
at the same time
[Music]
if you read the Mongolian history this
all about those brave warrior conquer
all around the world and they don't fear
death you know that kind of spirit
and mental people heavy-metal people
it's also like you know very manly you
don't give a [ __ ] you just do whatever
you want you know like this free spirit
is definitely free experience
people will say oh why you are doing
Mongolian music they don't understand
the whole ancestry thing they don't
understand your own culture identity but
at the end of day I love the Mongolian
culture and that's all what it matters
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]